investigation this went the clark county  water reclamation building it's in the  far east part of town near wetlands park  hector mejia reports  while the fire is out crews will be  keeping an eye on any leftover hot spots  the scene  is way back over there inside the  facility  we saw the haze of smoke earlier this  morning the good news is no one got hurt  around 8 30 this morning employees here  at the clark county water reclamation  district  first noticed something was wrong smoke  was coming from the building where the  wastewater enters the plant  a large odor control fan that filters  the smelly air  caught on fire the cause is under  investigation and we are told the  incident  did not disrupt the operations here  reporting in the east valley hector  mejia  8 news now